so really we mock people like that as
stupid but Underneath It All Is hey
that's what that is that's hate she
hates her fellow Americans who live in
East Palestine and places like it you
should know that Courtney Miller lives
in East Palestine she joins us tonight
Courtney thanks so much for coming on
um you're still there the Secretary of
Transportation came today do you think
the visit made a difference
not at all not at all just like every
meeting that they are trying to have
here it we never get answers everybody
gets to go around it's still nothing
they're not doing anything femos I was
told females supposed to be here
numerous times there's still no FEMA
anywhere I just don't understand I don't
understand why they're saying that
they're going to do it and then they
don't
are you I mean you're right around here
well I've noticed but your most pressing
concern has got to be the question of
whether it's safe to live there since
you lived there and like you probably
don't have a winter house in Palm Beach
so you're going to stay there or do you
know if it's safe to be there I mean has
anyone explained that no you don't know
um I don't know but I did a hire um
Scott Smith who's been taking samples
out of the creek in my backyard
um before they decided to try to dilute
it so that we couldn't get samples but
those samples were sent out those
samples are being tested for dioxins and
Vinyl chloride and multiple other
chemicals and they are not being sent to
anywhere near Ohio or Pennsylvania
they're being sent elsewhere in the
country and here soon within I'm hoping
the next couple of weeks we'll be able
to have results sooner than later and
then we can actually find out for sure
what is actually in that Creek and how
toxic it really is because as you can
see like I still don't sound the way I
did the last time we talked and that's
because I've been here for a couple days
and it's affecting my voice at this
point I sound very raspy and it's harder
to breathe and it was such a nice day
today it was 70 degrees I walked outside
and I sat down I wish I could say I took
a breath of fresh air but that's not the
case here
right it still smells it smells horrible
my Creek is terrible
it's just it's it's just like a gas
chamber that we're in you can't find
what you're not looking for and I know
that they're not looking for that as per
their results on their testing that
they've done and then they were
trespassing on my yard on top of it and
diluting The Creeks that I couldn't get
things it's
it's unreal the corruption
well if you're a Ukrainian you'd be a
top priority I'm just sorry they could
not Courtney Miller thanks so much for
that update from this Palestine
appreciated subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight